ever see a ghost
or because a lot of people haven't seen
a ghost anything unexplainable happened
in your life something like a psychic
tell you something or a dream that
predicted the future or like a place you
go you always get this weird feeling oh
and whenever the past that you felt like
is still a part of your life yeah that
you know I've never I'll start with the
I've never seen a ghost and believe and
very much believe in a lot of energy uh
around us uh and and
um it's one one face right here which is
like yeah just thank you [__] finally
thank you thanks Joe that means a lot I
know you can't hear me right now
I've just been feeling invisible for so
long I'm not seen you don't know what
it's like to be living as a dead thing
that died in 1901 hanging out party
specific well uh I fell and well oh man
it was the most embarrassing way to die
you look good still thank you I mean you
look very much like my friend Peter
home's hands well that's the form I'm
taking
he went into the well again I wish he
got most likely to find a well from his
high school year oh man well that worked
out well that's how often it happened
back then yeah this guy's falling as
well I mean he's luckily he made it out
looks like I don't know I don't know
he's still around I feel I haven't um
that's a good question I I don't uh I
haven't seen I know something weird has
happened to me before and nothing's
jumping that's what I mean it's hard
it's hard to find I realized I didn't
have an answer to that question
everybody knows as it listens to us
except every time I stay at my mom's
house the ghost of my mom's cat jumps on
the bed and it's every single time it's
it's it's the most reliable so I was a
person going around going like nah but
like sometimes they just get deleted
yeah I sometimes think our brains are
looking out for us and going like that's
sometimes something like I'll tell you
this or I'll ask you this does this make
sense to you that's my question
sometimes I have memory memories of
something happening and it's so weird
that I make a choice to just go like
let's just let that go it might be as
simple as a sound in your house yeah
just like if it happens again yeah I
don't mean like a bell look into it then
I'll look into it for jingling chains I
just mean like we do it all the time
life is so weird and we're just like
let's just let it go
um there was uh uh so at my house I have
a uh uh in my garage like I transformed
with my office it's a separate structure
is the point of this yeah freestyle
story and I'm we're in the main house
and um I'm I'm uh my son is uh I kind of
remember this right my son is we're
talking to my son about
something and he said
and I'm gonna forget her name let's say
her name is like Sasha she's like well
that's not what Sasha says and we're
like who's Sasha and he's like well
Sasha is the like a ghost the woman that
I saw here before I saw her in your
office oh no
and I and I I S and I'm like what does
she look like and he said she has like
like white hair and like a dress and I
mean you know like she said but I mean
thank you
the last name whatever it was and my
wife wait he gave you the last name he
gave yeah which I can't remember but he
gave me a first and last name and we
googled this name and this name was this
woman from old Hollywood that had bright
like blonde looking white hair and was
like a like a like a burlesque dancer
um that had it didn't say died in some
mysterious way but just the the the
point of the story is the picture that
came up was so much like what he said
that we were just like we're just gonna
let this go yeah we're just gonna let it
go my prompt unlocked yeah very good
ghost story yeah that happened and I
can't handle this and nothing has
happened in that office that's weird but
but it's almost scarier that it hasn't
because he's like I saw her in your
office not in the house yeah she's in
the office
um where I'm most did it have to be
where Dad's hanging out alone yeah yeah
couldn't it have been I'm sending my
emails yeah couldn't it been in a
communal area that's right maybe or even
in the yard you know if you could have a
ghost couldn't we be an outside ghost by
the way what if we get to a point where
ghosts are confirmed as a thing and
there are people going like can we get
these ghosts in the house look at what
we used to say in 2023 keep the ghosts
in the yard yeah keep they don't deserve
a little heat keep the ghost in the yard
they're already cold they always make
things colder when they're yeah exactly
right you know and in the summer they'll
be fine
[Music]